- [Narrator] This is Chris.
No, wait. That's not average enough.
(keyboard clicking)
James. Okay, this is James.
He just graduated with a bachelor's degree
and $30,000 in student loan debt,
which is a rounded average amount
of what most graduates
in the US end up with,
on which he pays a 5% interest rate,
which is again pretty average.
And this is Mary.
Mary also took out the exact same loan.
James's payment plan
allowed him to be debt free in 10 years
while Mary's repayment plan
meant that she ended up owing more money
after paying towards
the loan for a decade.
The Supreme Court is about to decide
the fate of President Biden's plan
to forgive up to $20,000
in student debt, but.
- That is by no means the only big thing
that the Biden administration
has done on student debt.
One of his other moves
that was actually announced
the same day as mass debt cancellation
got much less attention,
but is arguably gonna make
a much bigger difference
in the long run for
student loan borrowers.
- [Narrator] The other
big part of Biden's plan
will change how Mary, James,
and most other current
and future borrowers
will repay their student loans.
Here's how. Let's start with James.
On this loan, his monthly
payment would be $318,
and this is his payment schedule.
It's like a mortgage or car loan
where the interest essentially
gets paid off first.
So his first month, James
owes $125 in interest.
So the remaining $193
of his monthly payment
goes towards the loan's
original amount, the principle,
which then lowers his total balance.
It's called amortization.
Each month, less of his monthly payment
goes towards interest and
more towards the principle.
Those monthly payments make
his total amount paid go up
and his balance owed go down
until at the end of 10 years
he's paid off the loan
paying $38,000 in total.
James's experience is
what repayment looks like
for more than 40% of all
student loan borrowers.
While he can afford those monthly payments
on his $60,000 a year salary,
that's too much for Mary
who makes $30,000 a year.
So she did what nearly 40% of borrowers do
and went onto an
income-based repayment plan
which lowered her monthly
payment to around $68 a month.
But with amortization,
she still owes that $125 the first month
since it's the same loan as James,
but Mary's monthly
payment is less than that,
meaning there's nothing to go
towards the loan's principle
and her balance owed goes up.
Her monthly payments only
go towards the interest,
which makes her total amount paid go up,
but also her balance.
At the end of 10 years,
Mary has paid $8,000
towards her student loans,
but she still owes more than $38,000.
This situation is a common one.
The exact number of Marys is unknown,
but a Pew survey found
that two in five borrowers
owe more than they originally took out.
- I hear from people every single day
whose current balances,
even after they've been
paying off their student loans
for 5, 10, 15 years,
are larger than the
balance they started with.
- [Narrator] The income-driven
repayment programs
are set up to only last 20 or 25 years.
So in theory, people like Mary
will have paid $16,000 after two decades
and her then $53,000
balance would be forgiven,
but a government report
found that of all the
borrowers at that stage,
only 11% would be
eligible for forgiveness.
- It shows how common it is
that so few people are able
to complete these programs.
What's uncommon is successfully completing
the income-driven repayment
program as it was designed.
That's what's uncommon.
- [Narrator] If they miss one payment,
they become unenrolled in the program.
- They could have not submitted
their income recertification information,
which is necessary every single year,
or there could have been some data issue
where a payment to a servicer
did not get recorded properly
and as a result you are no longer eligible
to be part of this program.
- [Narrator] If that happened to Mary,
she would be on the hook
for her entire balance
with all that built up interest.
Re-enrolling in the
program is her only path
to earn forgiveness.
This is something President
Biden's student loan plan
attempts to fix.
Under the new system,
any interest Mary accrued
while on the income-driven
repayment plan would be forgiven,
so her payments would go
directly to the loan's principle
instead of just interest.
The new plan also changes the
rules around who qualifies
and lowers their monthly payments.
Mary, with her $30,000 a year salary,
would likely have no monthly payment.
Even James would be eligible
for a smaller monthly payment.
And dramatically, if
someone, let's say Robert,
has $12,000 or less in
undergraduate loans,
they would have their debt forgiven
after 10 years of small or
sometimes zero dollar payments.
- No one with an undergraduate
loan today or in the future,
whether for community college
or a four year college,
will have to pay more than 5%
of their discretionary income
to repay their loan.
- So this is really
shifting the boundaries
between what counts as a loan
and what counts as a grant.
This proposal probably goes farther
than President Biden intended to go,
at least while he was
campaigning for president,
but that largely reflects the reality
that nothing was getting done
in Congress on this issue
and he felt for political
or economic reasons
or other reasons that he
needed to move forward
on an executive action basis
or through using powers
that were available to him
under existing law.
- [Narrator] Powers not everyone agrees
he should be able to use for this.
- Because President Biden
couldn't get his radical
agenda through Congress,
he is dismantling the
Federal Student Loan Program
and pushing Democrat's free
college plan by executive fiat.
- [Narrator] These changes
go into effect in July
regardless of how the Supreme Court
rolls on debt forgiveness.
This plan is also going to be expensive.
One report found that while
forgiveness would cost the US
nearly $500 billion
over the next 10 years,
the changes to income-driven repayment
would cost 141 billion or more
as more borrowers take
advantage of the program.
While forgiveness is criticized
as solving a problem for the past
without creating a future solution,
this plan looks to change the way
student loans are handled going forward
so Mary doesn't end up owing
$60,000 for her $30,000 degree.
(bright music)